[Applause]
you know sometimes with these intros I
like to you know pull a memorable quote
from the thing I'm reviewing or
something the best quotes from this
would get me demonetised so we'll move
on so this one is a patreon sponsored
review because yes you can indeed hop on
to my patreon and if you are in a
spending mood throw some money at me and
make me review something I might not
otherwise be talking about and thus is
the case today and we are talking about
in Bruges I had seen this movie before
it had been a while and my memory of it
was that I thought it was pretty good
but I also thought it was pretty
overrated by a lot of people who I knew
or critics who I knew who really kind of
lost their minds over the thing a bit
and I was nervous to go back to it
because my thoughts on Martin McDonagh
the writer/director have now they
haven't improved I never got around to
seeing Seven Psychopaths I heard very
good things but it in addition to the
feeling that Umbridge was kind of a
rated I also had to contend with the
fact that I just don't like Sam Rockwell
I've mentioned that before I can't
account for that I just don't and then I
saw Liz and I saw three billboards
outside at Epping Missouri did not like
that movie with the exception of like
the montage that's part of Woody
Harrelson's characters thing I really
did not like that movie so I was
actually kind of afraid to go back and
watch in Bruges again I'm like oh god am
I gonna see way more problems with
I did last time um and the answer's no
but it also doesn't improve the
assessment that I had from last time I
saw the thing years ago I this film has
the taste of being made by someone who
usually works in theater which is Martin
McDonough's background and it's
something that I feel very strongly I
also felt very strongly coming out of
three billboards but it's something
that's very hard for me to quantify for
anyone who doesn't either go to theater
much or hasn't done theater or hasn't
you know had the opportunity to read
theater scripts versus movie scripts to
sort of get sort of the differences of
tone and flavor and things like that so
when I say that McDonough's approach to
filmmaking in in the two films of his
that I've seen like in fairness haven't
seen all of them it very much smells to
me of playwright as opposed to
screenwriter and it's not because of the
the like the superficial you know nature
of the medium things it's it's not like
this feels like oh they just took a play
and just stuck a camera it's not nice
I'm not talking about stuff like that it
just has to do with things like the
shifts and tones and the the way some
things play out I can sit there thinking
I feel like you might have gotten away
with that on stage and I'm not sure it
totally works in film there's some of
the transitions there's some of the mood
things and there's some of the things
that being in film adds that I don't
think help the big one being the music
yeah the music I feel is very at odds
with tone of this thing sometimes it
actually kind of betrays the way in
which I think this film is very high on
itself because the premise which I
haven't even gotten to yet got Michael I
got to my complaints early the premise
of and I would spoiler this
you know even explaining this because
the film in and of itself doesn't reveal
exactly what the deal with these two
people these two men is except that you
read even the basic pitch synopsis like
when you rent the thing from Amazon or
whatever or whatever it already says
this much so I'm just gonna go with this
you've got two hitmen hiding out in
Bruges which is a town in Belgium which
is a very well preserved medieval town
it's a bit of a low-key tourist spot you
know not the kind of place that people
flock to but you know does steady
business maintains you know what it what
it has through that and so you've got
these two hitmen played by Colin Farrell
and Brendan Gleeson and Brendan Gleeson
is kind of enjoy he seems to appreciate
where they are and the setting and what
there is to see and do and then the
architecture and they in the history and
Colin Farrell's absolutely bored out of
his mind it cannot stand it and they are
just there to hide out they're not there
on a job they're there because they were
told to go there and cool their heels so
they don't even know how long they're
gonna be there now both that premise of
sort of mismatched almost you know
team-up buddy
I mean that's it's not cop but that kind
of buddy cop mismatched pairing vibe
lends itself to comedy much more and
there's a lot of funny moments and not
like accidentally funny than it's quite
funny at times and over times verily
like very unsophisticated Lee I don't
mean like the throw like that was not a
sophisticated joke very crass I I just I
just mean like it's very blunt like then
this Colin Farrell's character comes
down from you know having gone up this
tower and he sees these American
tourists these fat American tourists
there well you can go there you've in I
mean I can't repeat what he says but you
know he just says you basically says
you're too fat to go up all those stairs
so you know the in debt and I'm not
saying that like that's not funny but
like that's not especially subversive or
subtle that's pretty blunt that's pretty
straightforward
and that's the kind of humor the thing
deals with and then honestly is at odds
at the I would say aggressively
thoughtful score the music is good taken
in a vacuum but it's the soundtrack to
like this slow contemplative piece which
seems to be what the film wants to be
while it is giving us characters who
swear absolutely non-stop and are
throwing around these very crass jokes
about fat Americans and little people
and you know very you know gallows death
humor and things like that ended they
don't gel and I think the music is a big
part of why they don't because the music
is hammering the more thoughtful tone so
hard that it isn't balancing with the
humor you can have something more
comedic and have it's a thoughtful
undercurrent to it but the music and
also how long this thing is how ient
lingers on some shots and how just long
the runtime is it's longer than it needs
to be to do what it's trying to do it
gets overindulgent it seems to be very
self assured that what it's doing is
really important and that and the music
and the length really kind of speaks to
this sense of self-importance that the
film kind of has which again is annoying
because there's a lot to like about the
film the performances are great and the
characters are interesting which was
honestly
also true of three billboards as much as
I openly dislike to that movie the
characters were still interesting and
they were all well performed so if
McDonough has a strength it is
absolutely in character if he has a
weakness it is in it is understanding
whether or not he even has a point to
make and understanding how much strength
there is in that
point because the things that this story
is dealing with thematically in terms of
finding a purpose in one's life you know
and how staying to one's principles the
consequences of actions and you know all
of all of these sorts of things playing
into it and they can absolutely be in
this film the themes aren't misplaced in
the story but again the presentation
making it feel like this is a big thumb
attic piece when it's just functionally
and demonstrably not it's a it is it's a
bouncy you know somewhat vulgar comedy
piece that can have these themes running
through it but it's like there are times
when the thing stops dead so that they
can have a slow pan over a characters
face and some of the background and the
music can get all slow and moody and
piano II it's like the movies bang you
over the head would mean it's like you
know you could just let it speak for
itself
you didn't have to bang on it like this
so like he was the movie I actually
found myself thank you up and this is
probably gonna be an ill-advised
comparison cuz this is a movie I find
almost nobody saw but I'm gonna compare
it anyways and consider it a
recommendation if you haven't seen it so
there's a film called four lions which
is a British dark comedy about four
would-be terrorists planning a suicide
bombing and similarly there are a lot of
themes of the value of human life and
the value one puts on one's own life and
the effect that you have in the world
around you and the things that you do to
try and make it better and the thing is
all those themes run through it but that
film doesn't tip its hand as to be like
hey check out all our thematic layers
which is what it feels like in Bruges
keeps stopping that story dead to do
what something like for lions does is it
presents you the comedy front
and let's the theme simply run through
the story as opposed to stopping to
highlight the moments be like see
poignant no it just has this stuff
running through it and it makes for
lions honestly for me
a devastating film very funny but
incredibly bleak that movie broke me to
be completely honest in a way that in
bruges very much seems to want to do but
can't even come close because it's
wearing its intentions on its sleeve it
could have snuck all this thematic stuff
in under the radar where it still would
have hit and for me personally what I
landed much stronger being an
undercurrent something that built as
opposed to something the film stops to
highlight the one thing I'll give credit
is at the very least characters don't
sit around talking about the subtext
just flatly so that it ends up just
becoming text it doesn't make that
mistake so as far as films over playing
their hands in terms of laying out the
themes to blatantly instead of letting
them just be themes it doesn't commit
the most egregious sin which is to just
have characters basically speak the
message of the film and the themes of
the film it doesn't do that so I also
want to stress that as much as the film
front that this film frustrates me what
it does you what it does wrong I feel is
something that usually when it's done
wrong is done much worse than this
but in a way that almost makes it more
frustrating because it means that it's
even closer to making this work
and but it's still not there elite again
I know a lot of people love this movie
so that's me also putting my hands up
maybe I'm missing something maybe
there's something I don't get I'm kind
of prepared to accept that cuz again
it's not badly made I don't think it's a
bad movie but I do think that it doesn't
fully work between the way that its
presenting things which like as it is
pretty joke Laden and that transitions
into the more action II stuff towards
the end well enough but everything feels
very bogged down by the heavy
themeing x' and the slow moments that
don't feel natural and feel very
injected into the thing for more often
than not there are a handful that work
but there's way more than there needs to
be this thing needs it needs the score
to be either rewritten or scrapped and
it needs about 10-15 minutes cut out of
it and then honestly it could have been
a really brilliant dark comedy with
these themes running through it and just
and just being there for people to
discover as opposed to you know feeling
like they're getting circled and going
here look we're so deep and again not
not I'm playing it up slightly for
comedic effect and to make the point but
it's not as blatant as it's not as win
is that as far as as far as laying out
what its themes are but I do feel it is
very blatant in trying to push the idea
we have themes we are poignant ah not
necessary and as a result the movie
while not bad irritates me so that's in
Bruges that's what it is for me at any
rate makes you get through this one
without too many spoilers I'm like I
mean the stuff that's good is really
good and that is primarily the
performances and the writing is solid
like the the massive the big promises
direction and editing streamline those
two things and it could have been it
could have been really good as it stands
it's pretty good with more potential to
be more than it actually is
I mean as good as all the performances
are in it refine steals the show so just
be aware of that he shows up later and
he's amazing
so there you go you seen it what are
your thoughts on it I have a feeling I'm
gonna take some people off with this one
like is that it seems like a film that
almost everyone I know it holds in
higher esteem than I do bit like how I
feel about No Country for Old Men
amongst other things anyway God how many
bears am I gonna poke drops on me down
in the comments let's talk about it
there's a whole bunch of stuff down
there as well
there's the patient
I mentioned at the front end helps me
cover my bills even at a dollar a month
even if you can't actually throw enough
money at me to Commission to review
something though that's always an option
like/subscribe those two buttons they
help me quite a bit and there's other
links besides click on them they take
your places
or don't I'd like you to but you don't
have to cuz at the end of the day you're
the council
I'm just running the meetings until next
time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]